-You look great.
I like the pink hair.
I don't think I've ever seen
the pink hair on you.
You look fantastic.
-Thank-- I was going to say
I like your beard.
-What?
This is like a compliment-off,
'cause I like your jacket.
-Your suit's okay.
-Thank you.
[ Laughter ]
You got to have goals.
-I've been going to the same
hair wizard for a while.
That's what I call her,
my hair wizard.
-Who is the hair wizard?
Do I know her?
-Her name is Marcy.
She's a big fan of yours.
-Oh, hi, Marcy.
-Wait, no, say, "Hola, Marcy."
-Hola, Marcy.
-Ooh.
-She's a hair wizard you say?
-Yeah.
Like, I feel like she -- one of
the first times I went to her,
she told me that she loves hair,
but she fears hair...
[ Laughter ]
...because hair is
like the ocean.
It's full of secrets.
[ Laughter ]
So, I knew that I needed her.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
So, the hair is full of secrets.
So, explain what happened
if you went to go see Marcy.
-Well, what I love about her is
that she says,
"You don't tell me what to do.
Your hair tells me what to do."
[ Laughter ]
So, I mean, I guess my hair
wanted to be pink.
-Wow. She's right.
[ Laughter ]
It looks fantastic.
-You should go to Marcy.
[ Laughter ]
No, no, no.
-My hair has too many secrets.
[ Laughter ]
Julio, I wanted to ask you
a question because I know you
as a writer, as a stand-up --
a great stand-up, an actor.
But you're getting
into something that's
a territory I know nothing
about.
-Okay.
-This is hand acting.
Do you know what
I'm talking about?
-Yeah, of course I know what
you're talking about.
Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
I meant to say that
to the audience.
Do you guys know
what I'm talking about?
Hand acting, can you explain to
everyone what this is?
-Yeah, I mean, I've seen a lot
of actors out there "acting,"
but then I look at their hands,
and their hands aren't
quite performing.
So, maybe I'll just show you.
Okay.
So, I'm going to give you,
like, a few scenarios
and just some tricks
for actors out there
if they want to implement them.
-This is awesome.
-Like for example, this would be
what you would do with a line
like, "Perhaps you can come to
my room later..."
[ Laughter ]
"...and then
we can see what happens?"
[ Laughter and applause ]
-That just got
an eight-minute ovation
at the Venice Film Festival.
-Yeah, yeah. Okay.
I'm gonna give you another one.
"Dolores, I need Roger
on the line."
[ Laughter ]
That tells a story.
-Yes, Dolores.
-Who is Dolores? Who is Roger?
-Of course, yeah.
-Okay, I'm going to give you
another one.
Do you have, like, a pen
and paper that I can borrow?
-Yeah.
-Oh, right there.
Yeah. There, there, there.
Okay. This is...
This is finally signing
the divorce papers.
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, my good-- Wow!
Oh! Fine! Fine!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Ah, that's so -- Alright, fine!
You got me.
-Do you have -- Do you have,
like, a cup or, like,
a wine glass or, like, a...
Yeah, with a stem. Yeah, that's
good. That's good.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
So, this is how you would
portray --
This is how only with your hands
you convey to the camera that,
"Yes, in fact,
there's poison in there."
[ Laughter ]
-Yes, in fact, there is poison.
-There's poison.
-There's poison in there.
-Do you have, like, a...
[ Laughter ]
Do you have, like -- I want to
say, like, a vial of potion?
[ Laughter and applause ]
Okay. So, here.
You offer the potion.
But you give a warning because
everything comes at a price.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Unbelievable.
That is why -- That's why
you're a professional.
Unbelievable.
-I'm a master.
-"Los Espookys." Season two.
I've been waiting for this
for a long time.
I loved season one, and then you
were filming and then pandemic?
-Yeah, so, we did season one.
Then we were going to do
season two.
And then this virus happened.
-Mm. And then --
-Spread throughout the world.
-So you shut down.
-So we had to shut down.
So, we did almost four episodes,
and then we took a little break
for two years.
-That's not --
[ Laughter ]
-We took -- They were like,
"Okay, we're breaking.
Like, snack time for two years."
-Two years? Is that helpful? No.
That can't be helpful.
-Some people are like, "Oh, that
must have been so awful."
And then it's like,
"Did we learn something through
stopping?"
No.
[ Laughter ]
Was it good creatively?
Like, no.
[ Laughter ]
It was like, "actually I really,
really don't recommend --"
My advice would be,
if you are doing something
and it's going well, don't take
a break for two years.
-Okay, that's good advice.
[ Laughter ]
How would you sum up the show
for us?
-I would say,
"Watch it, please."
[ Laughter ]
It's right -- You just open your
laptop and you da, da, da.
And then you just watch it.
[ Laughter ]
-This is meant for
laptop viewing?
-I mean, let's face it,
how many -- you know.
[ Laughter ]
I don't know.
Do you guys have televisions?
-Yes, we all have televisions!
You're on it right now.
-I know.
But, like, people are seeing it
on their phones.
-Oh, this is interesting.
[ Laughter ]
-There's this whole worldwide
web out there.
[ Laughter ]
-W-W-What?
Tell me about it.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-No, watch it on TV.
-I want to show everyone a clip.
Here's Julio Torres in the new
season of "Los Espookys."
Take a look at this.
-[ Speaking in Spanish ]
-Julio Torres, everyone.
Season two of "Los Espookys"
premieres September 16th
on HBO and HBO Max.